this program is being presented to you
by the heras international winter school
on gravity and
[Music]
light good morning and welcome to
lecture 7 of the winter school today we
talk about
Connections and uh today there is a
certain uh uh new part of the course
because whatever we did so far the
underlying set topology topological
manifold smooth manifold the
construction of the bundle all of that
is structure you need to provide by hand
before you can start doing physics as we
know it why because we don't have
equations that determine what happened
so far this is these are assumptions you
need to um submit before you can start
the physics today we introduce yet
another structure on a smooth manifold
so-called connections they also go under
the name of covariant derivatives but
actually there is a a difference between
connections and covariant derivatives
but for our purposes we will never talk
about this difference connections is the
slightly more General
notion but the connection in SpaceTime
will be determined by Einstein's
equations and actually sense equations
will determine a metric which is a even
more special structure which in turn
determines a connection but everything
from now on will be objects that are the
subject of Einstein's equations they
will be determined by Ein sense
equations depending on the matter that
is in the universe having said that we
continue in this mathematical fashion I
only make these Illusions to physics in
order to give you some
orientation okay so connections and um
uh so
far uh we
saw that a vector
field a vector field and we always wrote
shy for a vector field but now I write X
where X before was reserved for vectors
but from now on we will only talk about
Vector Fields unless unless anything
special uh is said
uh that we
don't we saw and therefore I just Ed
this notation for the vector field and
after all a vector field is just a
vector at every point the whole bundle
construction the last lecture was only
necessary in order to speak about a
smooth Vector field in a precise manner
but for all the intuition you need to
look at the formula even to interpret
the formula most of the time it's good
enough to think a vector at each point
okay so therefore we'll also indicate
Vector Fields with just these Capital
Latin letters so we saw that a vector
field X can be
used to provide or does provide can be
used to provide a directional
derivative and after all this was the
whole idea of each tangent space that it
contains all the direction derivatives
we called them velocities all the
directional derivative
operators um x
f of a
function f that had to be a smooth
function okay and uh what I will do now
in order
to remind you that this is directional
derivative I will introduce yet another
definition yet another symbol Nam I'll
say this is the directional derivative
of f in the Direction X this looks like
engineering mathematics right I will
introduce okay this this but it acts
only on functions we can only do
directional derivatives of functions so
far okay so
remark from now on
consider
mostly Vector
Fields now this seems absolute
notational
Overkill because we have this XF and we
know perfectly well what what it means
it's directional derivatives we know
this is in some
TPM well if it's a field in each TPM
there is a is a vector provided by the
vector field and we know this acts as a
directional derivative and we already do
have a different notation for this Nam
the one that works like this we have the
D of the F which if we plug in a vector
or vector field we get this function XF
now Vector on function gives number but
Vector field on a function gives a
function again we already have an
alternative notation and now I bother
you with yet another notation and that
certainly seems Overkill we have three
notations for precisely the same
thing now the reason is for this is it's
not quite the same thing not quite well
this is of course these are equal signs
but the objects that appear are
different you know that a vector field
may eat a function and spits out a
function that's what happens
here whereas the
DF takes a slightly different
perspective on what's going on here
because it eats a vector field a smooth
Vector
field and only after doing that it spits
out a function
okay but now you certainly say okay but
now really the D X down here this is
really precisely the same thing as the X
you're just emphasizing that it's a
derivative but you put the vector field
down here so now this certainly goes
again from C Infinity M to C Infinity M
so maybe you still see there may be some
value in this because it changes the
perspective of of what is the argument
and what is the function but this
certain is the same as this absolutely
right so this is to Total notational
Overkill but it's introduced for the
following reason this guy here can be
generalized to
extend to the following to eating an
arbitrary PQ tensor
field and then to yield again a PQ
tensor
field this guy can only eat
functions but now we also want to be
able to act not only on z00 tensor
fields which are functions we want to
extend the action of a directional
derivative to arbitrary arbitrary PQ
tensor fields for instance to Vector
fields we want to be able to talk about
the directional derivative of a vector
field for instance this is needed okay
and that's the idea and now again it
wouldn't be necessary to invent a new
symbol if this extension came for free
if this was on any smooth manifold
defined automatically we wouldn't get
the idea of introducing a new
symbol however it doesn't come
automatically you need
even if you require all the properties
you wish to have of a directional
derivative you still need to provide
extra structure on the manifold in order
to get such a directional derivative on
non functions on
tensors okay and this symbol will stand
exactly for this additional structure so
we need a new symbol and this only means
that the new structure if it acts on f
it doesn't require the new structure you
need in the general case on the
functions it still acts like this hence
this was a definition but only if it
acts on functions okay that's the
idea okay so um first section is
directional
derivatives of tensor fields
now how do we go about this how do we
get direction derivatives well and what
is the appropriate strcture structure to
establish it's very simple what we do we
just first require what we would a
directional derivative to
satisfy and then we see what structure
that
contains so
um
we
ask we postulate yeah postulate um we
formulate a wish list we formulate a
wish
list of
properties
which the NAA
X
acting on tensor fields
or on a tensor field because in each
instance it acts on a particular tensor
field uh should
have and uh we put this into the form of
a
definition and after we made the wish
list there may be still remaining
Freedom there may be many structures
that satisfy the wish list and will be
important for us to find out how
many or how to parameterize these
different structures because we will
have to pick one and on another occasion
we may pick another one so we need to
identify the in type of information and
the amount of information we will need
to provide as extra structure in order
to fix a particular such coant
derivative right so um let's make here
any
remaining after these wish list has been
satisfied any remaining
freedom in
choosing such a structure or maybe I
write it without the without the X
you'll see in a second why any remaining
freedom in choosing such a nabler I I
will call this nabler it's actually
called the coant derivative and so on
but let's call this nabler as a symbol
okay but it's of course not the naer
from engineering mathematics uh any
remaining freedom in choosing nabler
will need to be
provided as additional
structure
beyond the structure we already have and
we assume that all this takes place on a
smooth man manold so you already have
your smooth manifold but there might be
or there will be additional structure so
definition a connection
nabler a connection nabler and
uh so in the literature there's also the
name a linear connection that's more
precise but we will not look at
nonlinear ones so we don't need to
mention it all the time it goes mostly
under the name of
covariant
derivative which very much emphasizes
the way in which we use it and um some
people like shinger call it an
fine
connection and so on so these are all
different names uh I will probably also
use very often covariant derivative for
our purposes this is supposed to be the
same a connection nabler on a smooth
manifold
m o
a is a map what else is a map that
takes a
pair
consisting
of a
vector and here I say vector
field but actually this particular piece
of data this x down here it suffices if
it's only a vector at one point I'll
talk about this again but first please
read this as Vector field because this
is certainly true and the other thing is
a subtlety that in some points comes
points comes in okay consisting of a
vector field and a
PQ
tensor field now here the field is
important and cannot be substituted by
just a tensor and the PQ tensor field
that takes those and um sends
them to a
PQ tensor field and in order to be less
cryptic I should probably say a vector
field X and the PQ tensor field T and
sends these two to a PQ tensor field
that we denote nabla down
X on T and if we took here a vector
field it's a tensor field and if we took
here only a vector it only sends it to a
vector at the same point where this
Vector was
attached it's very much like taking here
just a vector and acting on a function
you get a number namely the directional
derivative of the function in the
Direction X at the point where the X
lives then you get just a real number
but if you take here a vector field
acting on a function you get an entire
field because you do this point by point
it's precisely the same logic here and
so if you put here the field you need to
put here the field if you don't put here
the field you can't put here the field
okay but for first understanding ignore
the brackets
um is a map
satisfying and now come four
properties the first property is very
simple it just requires that if the
symbol acts on a z0 tensor field it
simply acts by action of the vector
field so that is what I already wrote
down very simple now in writing down
further the further aims will only will
work for General tensor Fields so this
is for all 0 tensor
Fields the following three aims will all
talk about the action on an arbitrary PQ
tensor field but you can imagine PQ
could be zero so anything I write down
now should be a property of this in the
first place because otherwise we get an
inconsistency with number one right and
on the problem sheets today on on in the
in the examples classes uh you will
actually check this that this works out
it's a very good exercise in seeing
where's an object defined where's this
multiplication defined and so on and so
on okay so please as always go to the
problem classes so uh the second
requirement we have is that if we act on
two tensors of the same type so both T
and S are PQ tensors otherwise I
couldn't add them okay then we require
that this is additive in the tensor
fields on which it
acts so this is supposed to be true very
simple now
uh it could the following could happen
you could have a tensor t a PQ tensor
but I will now write it down for a one
one tensor because then you know it all
okay so you could have a one one tensor
um which is already evaluated on a co-
Vector field and a vector field if that
is the case then um this is
already a smooth function is that clear
if you plug into a one one tensor a co-
Vector field and a vector field it's
fully evaluated it gives you a function
so that means the left hand side is
already determined by this thing up here
but now the question is or what yeah
it's not the question it's it's a
postulate here you wish that this equal
Del XT the covariant derivative of the
tensor itself and once you calculated
the derivative you
evaluate on these two Fields
plus you have the tensor and you derive
the first one the co- Vector field and
you keep the vector field the way it is
plus you keep the co- Vector field as it
is and you derive the co vector field
full
stop so in other words this guy you
already know how to calculate but you
can represent this by the action of this
guy on just everything that is in here
one after the other okay and so this is
for a one one tensor for a one one
tensor field
T but
precisely well but analog
ously for
any
PQ tensor field okay so if you had one
more entry Z for another Vector field
would be a one two tensor you need plus
T Omega y comma NAA x z and the same if
you had another covector field here okay
I could write it down with dots but I
don't think that serves Clarity more
than this
okay this rule up here could be called
um well uh it's the that NAA X is an
extension that's the extension rule uh
this is the additivity in the argument
and this is called the LI nits
rule this is called the light nits
Rule and uh finally the fourth rule is
that the whole object is C Infinity
linear in the lower entry so if down
here FX
plus uh Z acting on some tensor T if you
have this then you may split this it's
additive in there so you have a nabl FX
Z plus nabla uh no FX t plus NAA z t but
it's also C Infinity linear so the F can
jump in front so this is indeed for
functions F appearing here in this form
this is the C Infinity linearity in the
lower slot whereas in the slot it acts
on it's only additive but if you have
here a function f it needs to be treated
uh like like a tensor uh like a tensor
product with a product rule
okay so those are the um the aums we
would like like to impose in any such
structure la la la la any such such
structure is called a covariant
derivative that's the nabler and uh we
say um
a um manifold with Conn
action is a quadruple of
structures m o a smooth manifold and now
yet on top another structure namely such
a specific such uh object that's
satisfies these
rules the question is is there a unique
such object or is there an amount of
choice I make if I pick a particular one
whichever I pick it satisfies these
rules and it will serve as well but
there may be many ways to satisfy these
rules and indeed there is some remaining
freedom but it's fully under control and
again yes just the question you stressed
that the F need not be
the the F must be so it's only the entry
down
here it's only the entry down here
yes so it's meaningful to talk about the
directional derivative of a
field in the direction at a point there
are derivatives like the lead derivative
where you cannot ask for the lead
derivative of a field of a tensor field
in One Direction at one point because
the Le derivative uses an entire
Direction field in order to calculate
the lead derivative in that in the
direction of that field of another field
okay but here this is like that and um
if I hadn't emphasized it uh you would
have said ah this thing is C Infinity
linear down here what does the C
Infinity linearity really mean forget
about the the Z just look at nabla FX on
T it means you can
scale if even if x is a field you could
scale the field at any point at every
point in a different fashion
right but the result if you then
evaluate at the point P the result would
only depend on the scaling you chose at
the point where you evaluate so however
you change the field
in the neighborhood of this point where
you evaluate doesn't have an effect on
the
result the only effect is how the
function how the scaling is at that
point and that tells you you don't need
the field values in the neighborhood
because they don't go into the result so
the C Infinity linearity in something
tells you you put in a field but you
wouldn't have needed a field do you
remember the definition of a tensor
field a tensor field is something that's
C Infinity linear in all the slots that
means even if you plug in Vector fields
and co- Vector fields at a point you
could evaluate by just plugging in the
values of these fields you plug in at
that point how the field behaves next to
it doesn't matter that's the whole
secret of looking at V tensors so that
you at the end know something at a point
okay so these brackets could be read off
with some experience from this postulate
of C Infinity linearity if if you think
about it okay so um that as a side
remark
yes I yes usually comes in with just
demanding linearity just demanding
that we have that because um it would
not even
fit this instance because here um you
would have
nabla X acting on function times
function this would then be the 0 0
tensor field this would be the function
multiplying it which is of course both
functions and you know this is x f * G
and there is a product rule there is XF
* G plus
fxg and not time um there's there's a
times there is not there's a times
linearity C Infinity linearity would
mean you have only this term you can
pull the F out but in fact you have a
product rule because it's a derivative
so requiring here more than additivity
any derivative is additive in the object
it adds on acts on but it's certainly
not C Infinity linear because you need a
product rule and in fact if you want to
calculate this therefore you need to go
to what I call the liet rule
here
okay so um so this is a manifold with
connection or an fine manifold there
many names around for this this is the
one we want to use a manifold with
connection is a
quadruple um before we identify the
remaining Freedom let me make the remark
um if you look at this um you see that
if you leave out the
X
um you see the following if d x is the
extension
of the action of X as it acts on a
function it's the extension to tensors
in the way I described before then you
might ask what is the nabler itself
without having
filled the lower slot what is this the
extension
of um this is the extension of the
D you see it here the nbla alone is the
extension of the D you need to feed the
nabler and X in some fashion before it
then can act on a function okay so um
this will come well this is just
notational uh nonsense right I mean
we're talking about notation this has no
depth but sometimes one wonders well why
is the structure why does it come with
an X well it doesn't really it's just
that this is more easily formulated if
you think of it like that I could have
formulated it all as an extension of
this and uh that's uh yet another level
of uh obscurity in here which is not
needed okay but if you ask what is this
generalization of it's the
generalization of the D okay now the
important question is how many such
structures are there uh so what is the
new structure
required new structure on
M A
required uh to
fix
nabler I can require
all right but is it fixed by this and in
order so the question is how much
freedom is
left how much
Freedom do we
have in
choosing such a
structure and um it turns out that it's
useful to First consider the following
case um certainly if we want to be able
to do something with this we need to be
able to act on a vector field that would
be the simplest or one of the simplest
examples Beyond acting on functions
let's study this case and see what we
learn so consider uh Vector Fields let's
have them both as Fields Vector
fields and let's calculate this now once
please once we're at this
point we don't know what to do because
we say okay you have such a structure
you apply it to a vector field what do
you do well let's do the following in
order to understand what kind of data is
in there we would like to maybe get
numbers and you always get numbers by
going to a chart so you consider the
situation you have here locally in a
chart okay so um in a chart you can
certainly expand the X in the chart in
US spaces and the y in the chart in you
spaces let's do that so you get x i d by
DX I because I don't have a point here
it's the vector field d by dxi and this
whole thing acts on some ym d by
DXM so I can put brackets here in order
to make clear the nabler acts on all of
that that is certainly true what do we
learn well we learn that um in order to
understand this we can do several things
this is a vector field and these are
functions that are by a
sum multiply this Vector field because
the expansion of the vector field X you
can pull the sum out that is the
additivity down here but you can also
you pull then the um individual
functions out so you get here x i nabla
d by DX I of course the vector field you
cannot pull out so this object is
actually this and now it acts on this
but this is a function that's Z 0 tensor
this is 01
tensor sorry a one zero tensor using the
lipet rule you get from this ym it acts
on this
one and it then
evaluates at this one no sorry it
doesn't evaluate that's sorry it's it's
a product with
d d by
DXM
plus lightnet rule the same object x i d
by
dxi sorry it keeps this one and it
multiplies with the
application d by DX I acting on D by
DXM that is what it does that's
according to the lipnet
rule and then we know what to do because
this guy is a vector field acting on a
function for each M this is a function
so this is x i the vector field acts
directly on the
function this is aim one so this is uh
three and this is one
and you re you keep the the spaces so
these are numbers or functions this is a
basis of course because the
result according to the definition must
be a vector field again because the Y is
a vector field and this is of course
already a vector field expansion plus x
i ym what do we do here well this guy we
can no further cannot do anything with
any further in this chart we don't know
indeed these this here what is this what
is the result well it's a vector field
because this is a vector field you act
on a vector field you get a vector field
whatever it is whatever Vector field it
is you can expand it in the chart right
if this is a vector field you can expand
it that means you can write it as d by
DX q and it has some coefficient
functions let's call them gamma
Q if this is a vector field it must be
you must be able to write it like this
coefficient functions gamma Q expanded
in terms of these basis Vector fields in
the chart right but the gamma Q's will
certainly depend whether you chose here
the first or the second or the third or
here the first or the second or the
third so they depend on what I and M you
chose so we should give them the name I
uh M and I in this
order so depending on i and m this will
be coefficient functions and this Q is
the
expansion these guys are very important
and they have a specific name these guys
are called the um
connection because it refers to this
guy coefficient
because it's the coefficients of this
expansion functions because they're
indeed functions and they functions on
the manifold uh we could make them
functions on the chart but we rather
prefer to think of them as functions on
the manifold on the
U the indices refer to the Chart but we
could think of them as functions as a
collection of functions push down to the
chart and they eat a point in the chart
or we think of them as eating the point
in the manifold where they come from we
prefer to eat them the point in the
manifold we will come to this in a
second so these are the connection
coefficient
functions of nabla with respect to the
Chart ux obviously if I had chosen
another chart for the same object they
would take different
values that's what I was going to ask we
introduced them with indes yes how can I
think of them as chart independent
they're not they're highly not chart
independent the indices indeed indicate
they depend on the chart but you can
even of a chart um dependent object you
if it's a function you could think of it
as being a function of the point in the
chart because it changes from point to
point in the chart but it's clever to
think of these chart dependent objects
from point to point not as a function of
the point in the chart but as a function
of a point up there and there is no
problem because you have a one to one
map x and x inverse between the points
down there and the points up there it's
just the formula becomes simpler if we
do otherwise we have formula where we
always have a composition with the X
inverse in it with the x or the X
inverse this way we save that trouble
okay we we we'll come to that okay so I
give a definition so I give a definition
yes
yes yes so uh that I leave you as a
homework the point is the way I no no
the way no it's important that you try
that the way I formulated the lipets
rule it could have also been formulated
like T tensor s equals NAA x t tensor S
Plus T tensor na
Xs and the tensor product is an
incredibly simple object well it's not
the tensor product between Vector space
it's the tensor product between vectors
in this case tensors and the tensor
product between tensors is T tensor s um
if T is a um PQ tensor and S is an RS
tensor then the tensor product is a p+ r
q plus s tensor it depends on
correspondingly many omegas and Vector
Fields X's co- Vector fields in Vector
fields and it's simply defined as T of
the first P co- Vector
fields and the
first R Vector Fields times the S times
the remaining co- Vector Fields
remaining q and the remaining s Vector
fields and this is just a multiplication
in r or if these are Fields a
multiplication in C Infinity r m okay so
this is the Tor product and maybe in
this form it reminds you even more of
the standard product rule okay and
however my uh formulation of the liet
rule already combined these two
definitions so I didn't have to
introduce the tensor product but thanks
to your question I had to do it
anyway
okay maybe I can
here this is this is a Q This is a
q okay A little
Q how do know
from pardon me how do we know
from ah um well because I say it here
and uh Yas wants me to write a little X
here in order to indicate it's a chart
depend object and that's a clever thing
to do and whenever I don't do it I
should do it and especially when we talk
about different charts of course it
becomes mandatory to do it so we don't
get confused as long as we talk about
one chart we may suppress this but it's
certainly better to first put it there
until we get tired of it and then we
drop it okay it's a good pedagogical
principle um okay so but let me give you
a precise
definition
definition you have a manifold with
connection and you have a chart ux from
the
atlas then the uh
connection
coefficient
functions and uh you see connection
coefficient functions is a lot of
writing I could write CCF uh but really
what mathematicians and physicist refer
to them is the gamas right the
connection coefficient are the gamas uh
are given by with respect to the Chart
ux
are the dim
m to the third many
functions gamma i j k from the domain of
the chart
each into the real
numbers given
by um
DX I acting on
nabla D by D X and now comes an
important point it's a convention but
it's important if you put the K here the
last one corresponds to the index that's
on the object that's down here XK d by
DX J and if you want to think of it as
this map it Maps this to well this is a
vector field after deriving it it's
still a vector field a co- Vector field
acts on it so this is a function and you
evaluate if you wish at the point P
because it's a function on the manifold
hence the GMA is a function on the
manifold okay so this looks terrible but
this is really a part uh that you have
to think of this is a vector field you
could expand it then has these expansion
coefficients but you extract its I
component by acting by the dxi as always
okay so this is the precise definition
and this also shows that it's indeed a
collection of functions chart dependent
functions but nevertheless functions on
the
manifold other examples for chart
dependent functions that are defined on
the manifold well the coordinate
functions the 1 to XD they functions
from U to R and they're obviously chart
dependent because they Define the chart
okay so this is nothing nothing unusual
these are the connection
coefficient
functions all right so apparently so
using
them we have that actually NAA X on Y is
a vector field hence it has
components I I can expand
it I can expand it in terms of the D by
dxi but that means it has components x i
that are given as
XM d by
DXM acting on the y i
functions it's very important whether
the I is inside the bracket or outside
inside the bracket means this is a
function namely a component function of
the vector field if the I was outside
the bracket which it is not here I just
put it here for a moment then it would
mean you act with this on a vector well
you can't do this because this guy
doesn't act on vectors this is a vector
field doesn't act on a vector field like
this so it must be inside here but then
this has nothing to do with a vector
anymore it's are just component
functions of a vector so it acts like a
vector field acts on a function which
happens to be the member of a family and
this is the family member called I
okay it's this thing plus we just
calculated this over there plus
gamma
i m n and this m goes with the
XM and this n is the
YN and all of these are functions so the
product is all these products here are
products between functions so they're
pointwise defined if I would evaluate
then at a point point this would become
a value at a point a value at a point a
a number at a point so this would be
multiplications in R here they are in C
Infinity M okay same as here the result
is a function this is a product in C
Infinity M this is just an application
and so this is the addition is also in C
Infinity M okay this is actually a
rather simple way you may be shocked but
this is a simple way to express what
this thing does because if I provided
you with these dim M to the3 many
functions on the chart you are able to
calculate the directional derivative of
the Y with respect to
X but you say yeah well if you provided
me with so many functions well this is
the freedom that is left choice of so
many functions on a chart we first on
one chart how to go to Glo how to go
globally we'll do in a second but on one
chart you need to provide me so much
information it's a lot of
information but this is all the
information you need in order to do the
coant derivative of a
vector now you say okay but what about
the coent derivative of a coor field and
even worse what about the coant
derivative of a tensor field the fear is
you need more and more and more of these
coefficients the higher the rank of the
tensor field becomes that is not the
case
it turns out and I write it down in a
second it turns out that also if this D
X acts on a CO Vector field or in a
tensor field the same information is
needed these dim m to the three many
functions but they're used in a slightly
different way but only in a subtly
different way so you need to take
careful attention at the position of
indices that are contracted with what's
over there and at the signs in
front Okay so now um so first uh um
remark um on a
chart
domain
U
it um
choice of the dim
m to the
thir
functions gamma i j
k suffices
to
fix the
action of
nabla on a vector field on a vector
field
fortunately
fortunately the
same dim M to
the3 functions
fix the
action of nabler on any tensor
field the key observation to see this is
the
following if we want to act on a co-
Vector
field then obviously we can do the same
type of calculation up to the point
where we arrive at the elementary
question what is d by DXM because what's
down here will remain a vector field but
now it will act on a
dxi now remember is a dxi but these are
not functions these are not coefficients
but dxi denotes the I basis Vector in
the co space so if this is not at a
point it's a co- Vector field it's the I
basis co- Vector field this we cannot
further
reduce now the question is do we have to
require new gamas I know call them
Capital sigmas which now have a
different index structure because this
now has to this will certainly again be
a co- Vector field so we could expand it
in DX something and so on so the
question is do we have to
provide and of course we can
new coefficients let's call them Sigma
it's not a sum sign it's a sigma and
that would be something like
I uh m is bad uh uh q i q M's so
certainly we can do that so we have
functions Sigma they have now this
structure the question is are they
already expressed in terms of the gamas
and the answer is yes um also so now but
now
we do the following
consider the action of d by DXM on
something different consider the action
on the dxi acting on the D by
dxj what is this well we know this is a
vector field this is a co- Vector field
so this is a function inside here we
know how to deal with functions but we
chose here the Dual Fields so this is a
very special function is the function
that's either zero or one depending on I
so we know how to act with this guy this
guy acts like the vector acts because
this is a function so this is this
action of a vector on a function but
this is a constant function whatever I J
is so the result is zero aha what do we
learn well we learn if we go in this
direction we hold this take this entire
thing and this is another Prime
opportunity to use the liit rule
because this is one tensor and you plug
in other tensors so it's the lighten
rule this must be according to the liet
rule three must be the action of this on
that so that's the action of d by
DXM on the I co Vector
field and then you plug in D by DX
J plus you keep this I co Vector field
and you plug in the derivative nabla d
by
DXM on the D by
dxj and now you already see it coming
this gentleman here we know very well
this is
gamma um up
Q D by
dxq um m in the back J here
right and the other side is
zero so we can solve for this guy we
want to
know
therefore let me continue
here therefore um nabla d by
DXM acting on the I co Vector field is
if I act on the J Vector but that's the
definition of the J component of a co-
Vector field 10 acting on the J Vector
Co Vector acting on that is that is the
J equals and I take this to the other
side so you get a minus sign a fat minus
sign because of taking this to the other
side and you get dxi of this guy but
these are just functions they jump in
front of the XI the dxi acts on the D by
dxq to a Delta IQ so the Q becomes an i
gamma
I
JM aha so um if I had expanded here in
terms of JS instead of
Q's you see
indeed there are such coefficients Sigma
JM but they're nothing but minus gamma
JM so the rule for calculation the
pneumonic rule you keep in mind is
wherever you do this formula for vectors
you have it with a plus sign wherever
you do it for co- vectors or co- Vector
Fields you have it with a minus sign
okay so summary so
far and it is worth writing down this
Vector rule again without looking at it
and uh so this is now not mathematics
this is just memory but you need to
Commit This to Memory so you have the
following nabla on a vector field y in
the direction of an X will be a vector
field again so in components it will
have one component
up this component will be given by you
simply do the derivative X you act with
X on the component
function here I still wrote this as XMD
by DXM but this is just the X acting the
X acts on the I component function this
is engineering mathematics you do the
directional derivative on a fun on on on
on a vector field by doing the
directional derivatives of the
components of that Vector field and then
you're done well you're not because
there is a
plus and then there is a
gamma and now you need to be careful the
gamma has three entries and the last
entry is always for the direction in
which you go so if this last entry is a
j or what do you say an
M then you need an XM it's linear the
correction is linear in the direction
which you derive the result there's only
a position I that you can put here and
then there is a remaining J and that
takes the field that's being derived the
functions the coefficient functions of
that field okay so you see the uh the m
is always the last because it goes with
this direction and that will stay like
this and this here is the
result and then you have no more choice
that this must be here okay and you
remember the plus and the plus you
always
put because you act on a
vector field then you put the plus I
mean we derived this but you need need
to remember it like this now the other
thing we just derived is that the
covariant derivative of a co- Vector
field will be a co- Vector field so the
coefficient has an index
down this equals now you take the X and
you naively apply it to the coefficient
functions again also in engineering
mathematics you would act the
directional derivative of a c-vector
field you would just act on the
functions here on the coefficient
functions and then you feel you don't
need to make a difference between Vector
fields and coor Fields well
unfortunately that's not all of it you
need a minus sign all of a sudden and
then you have a gamma you have an M that
goes with an XM perfect so that's the
same thing but now you have to
distribute indices differently you have
two more positions open one down one up
one down the down index must remain a
free index so that's an I here you have
no other choice but to put another
summation index J here oh that fits
because the Omega J has the index
down okay so you have this rule here
that's the summary so far we derived
this and these rules you use all the
time in general relativity calculations
so you really need to commit them to
Memory and you need to have a method of
remembering where the indices are I try
to present you mine you may have your
own personal rule of how how to remember
this this was my rule and this is for
the action on Vector fields and co-
Vector Fields the important message is
the same gamas determine that now
similarly by application by further
application of the lightnet rule
similarly by
further
application of lip
nits you get the action
on a one one tensor field and once I
wrote that one down you know the action
on a one two tensor field or let's do
one two just for fun the action on a one
two tensor field will be a one two
tensor field according to the definition
that means you will have indices i j k
for the resulting coefficient functions
of the resulting tensor field okay if T
was a 13 tensor field
uh one two sorry one two tensor
field okay how does this go well very
simple it's already all there you act
with the X naively on the coefficient
functions of the one two tensor field
engineering mathematics
plus now for each index up you do this
Rule and you keep the under other
indices on the T untouched
and for each index down you apply this
Rule and you keep the other indices on
the capital T untouched let's do it we
do it for the upper index do it for the
upper index maybe here I move the
Blackboard up for the
camera index up you need a plus because
of the index up gamma the result will be
in I the um direction in which you go is
in M now this I refers to this index
here on on the T so you put the T here
because you put the I there the T can no
longer carry it you need to find a dummy
index s that is being summed over that
carries this the same rule applies up
there and then you keep the remaining
indices J K untouched and you need to
say it's in the Direction X that as
always goes with the last one now comes
a minus sign for each of the lower
indices how does this go there is a
gamma there's the M for the direction in
which you go it's the last index
there're two threee the T has indices up
down down now you are talking about the
first J index the gamma needs to know
about it because it's the turn of the J
index the J goes here you need a dummy
index where before the J was to sum over
it here the M sorry that's not it and
the other two you keep untouched I is
untouched K is untouched finally you
deal with the last index of the T so you
put here minus gamma the m is the one in
which direction you derive then there is
the T with three indices you're now
dealing with the K index so the gamma
needs to know about it but then where
the K index was there's going a dummy
index sorry there was um yeah that was
here the dummy index and the other two
indices of the K are left unti that's
it okay so uh you need to learn this
somehow study these rules find your own
rule plus minus minus because it's a one
two tensor one up two
down so again and similarly of course
for any other PQ tensor okay and in all
these cases it's the same dim m to the
three functions
gamma that determine
this
okay question so
far yes so this is lot of definitions
and I'm a little bit lost but so just
let me let me break down to very
simple everything in
aan I
guess if by a ukan space okay so the
question okay yeah yeah let's say
this okay so the question is if in a
ukian
space the
gamas
all
vanish in a then
existing Global
chart that's I I take the question like
this yes but what is a ukian space So my
answer would be
yes
but what is a ukian
space you can now give an answer to this
the answer is it is
an M that's an some
Rd uh it's equipped with the standard
topology and some smooth
Atlas right if you do it R3 you know you
have essentially unique Choice up to
diff morphism and so on we had this
okay but that doesn't make it you clear
in space that's just a smooth
manifold on a smooth manifold you have
no gamas what you now mean
is
assume that R3 comma the identity on R3
is a chart of the smooth
Atlas you can cover the whole R3 with
this identity map that's true that's not
the Assumption yet assume this but with
the idea and the gamma i j
k if this is the chart Map
X you what you're assuming is that the
gamma i j k in this
chart defined as the
dxi of the nabla D by DX k d by
dxj that they're all zero and that's a
choice you
make so yes they are they do all vanish
by definition of ukian
space so um the implication error is
like this so it's indeed right but you
could easily equip our three with a
non-trivial coant derivative
intuition
intuition the smooth manifold R3 up to
here well maybe R2 let's say intuition
for R2 with this construction is it
looks like this it's because because our
eyes already think about coant
derivatives because coant derivatives
identify a curvature or not that will be
the next lecture but this is this but
you could EAS so that's the naer you
chose okay so that's the
ukian na which in this one chart looks
like this so it defines the nuer on this
side if you set it to
zero uh that's ukian nabla but I could
choose the hyperbolic nabla on the same
smooth manifold and uh the intuition
would be it's such a
saddle right it's still still R3 it goes
infinitely in R2 it still goes
infinitely in all directions as a smooth
manifold but it has a curvature and it's
a saddle showing that ukian space is
exactly the choice of gamas of a
coordinate system where that globally
vanishes on this space there exists no
more a global coordinate system in which
all the gamas vanish
we'll come to that it's a very good
question
okay but also I just say it even on this
ukian space and that will be the topic
of the next section even on this ukian
space if you go to another
chart like polar coordinates or slightly
deformed linear nonlinearly deformed
chart map you will also get non-
Vanishing lambas although in this chart
you have them all Vanishing and this is
what you know again from engineering
mathematics you want to calculate the
gradient in polar coordinates well
what's the gradient the Divergence sorry
the Divergence so uh um definition
didn't want to bring it but let's do it
definition let X be a vector
field on a connect on a manifold with
connection so m o a assume you're given
some
connection then the
Divergence of
X is the
function on the
manifold
DivX which is defined as nabler in any
chart defined as d by DX I acting on the
X taking the I component and there is a
trace over
here and claim is I used a chart to
Define it or use charts to Define it
claim this definition is nevertheless
chart
independent the definition is but
depending on the chart if you go to a
chart if you have ukian space and you go
to a chart where the gamas vanish this
is just the uh the partial derivatives
of the coefficients and taking the sum
it's the engineering mathematics
Divergence if you're on the same space
you have the same physical situation the
same Vector field everything is the same
but you choose polar coordinates then
you still do these derivatives but you
have additional terms which you look up
in your formula
collection depending on what the
coordinat system is for spherical polar
coordinates for cylindrical coordinates
for elliptical Co whatever you find what
if you use coordinates that's not in
your formula collection it's very simple
you use the gamas it's always the gamas
so what you need to know is how do the
gamas look in other charts we're going
to do that but so all these different
lists in the formula collection is just
this one formula okay so you used it
already you used the gamas already
there's no such thing as I never used
that before and I don't need it you
do
okay yes the formula on the lower left
of thisable isn't that for
Co which this one yes uh well I don't
know if you want to call a coordinate
system in which the gamma vanish a
cartisian coordinate system you may
although in a cartisian coordinate
system you need something more you also
think of certain angles between the
coordinate lines you need a little more
you need a metric this will be called
Global or in the chart normal
coordinates we'll come back to that okay
so there's a remaining question is I
defined these gamas only on one chart
what if I have another chart well if the
chart is right over here it doesn't
matter you can def give these functions
but what if you define it on one these
scamers on one chart and you define them
on another chart but the charts do
partially overlap they needs to be a
compatibility you can't choose them here
like this and there like that and you
have different coari derivatives in the
overlap region depending on which chart
you're on so you need to check that so
you need to look at third change of
components of coefficient functions
change of
gamas yeah under change of
chart so how do we go about this well
it's very simple uh let's take ux and
VY uh both elements of the smooth
Atlas and um and assume they have an
overlap if the chart domains do not have
an overlap we have no problem if they do
have an overlap we can simply calculate
the gamma i j k in the Y chart and try
to related to the gamma i j k in the X
chart okay we need to see how these are
related so let's do this how is this
defined well this is defined as the DYI
acting on the
d by DX K last index acting on the D by
dxj that's the
definition of these guys and sorry X is
wrong is of course in the Y chart so
every x what was before an X is now a y
okay now what are what is this object
this object is these Yi are functions
right the Y eyes are functions and the D
acts on them so don't be blinded this
being a Yi and being well not summed
over but being a
Yi if this was a DF you would
immediately agree that you can write
this in components d f by d uh
x d f by
dxq time dxq if this was a DF you know
in the X chart you can expand it like
this right well it's not an F but it's a
Yi it's the I component function it's
nevertheless true and here it's not
evaluated at a point we leave it like
this as a as a vector field okay so this
is this now this acts on nabla there's a
d by Dy K that's the K spasis Vector now
I could argue by how basis vectors
transform but I could only also just
write down the product rule and the
chain rule this is d by
dxp dxp by Dy
K well it's not quite the product rule
because you know these are not partial
derivatives these are our symbols you
remember but you can show that these
symbols are expanded exactly like this
according to the chain rule for the
symbols it's not the chain rule from
undergraded analysis but it's directly
reducible to the chain rule from
undergraded analysis you can write this
thing like this of course my strategy is
wherever there was a y I want to get an
X into the game and this acts on D by
dyj this can be expanded as d by DX uh
uh k k LM what don't we have yet uh uh
UV r s s is good uh d x s by d y j so
this guy here acts on this okay nothing
happened nothing happened I just used
the chain rule a little now these are
again functions they jump in front
because of the C Infinity linearity down
here this is again a product so again
need to use the lipet rule let's execute
this this is DYI by
dxq now this is DX well let me write it
down once dxq on dxp by
Dy
K uh NAA d by D XP acting on and now I
do the product rule here it first acts
on the functions
DXs by Dy J and then d by DXs multipli
by this Vector plus but now I need to
repeat this guy here or I put a bracket
uh plus now this guy this is kept
DXs by Dy J and this guy this guy acts
on that guy but you see this is the
gamma well let me write it down um d by
dxp acting on D by DXs
uh yeah well it Xs like this and then
the the bracket closes okay this is this
so now we continue and we already look
at this very closely so there is a
DYI by
dxq in front let's do the first term
this is a co- Vector field these are
functions so these jump out of here too
these jump out of here so this is dxp by
d y k so now there is still this guy
acting on this stuff but these are just
functions so this will just act as a
function and it will jump out so this
will be D by D XP DXs by d y j so this
is a second derivative but not in the
same variable so we got to be careful
but this is of course right uh this acts
on this and the only Vector field part
still standing under the DX Q is this
one but what is dxq on D by DXs it's a
Delta Down s up Q because these are dual
bases that's the first part now comes
the second part we start with this one
is the dy I by
dxq dxq acts on here this is a function
that jumps out just like that because of
C Infinity linearity of this Co Vector
field DXs by dyj this jumps out and then
there acts dxq on D by dxp D by DX is a
we know what that is this is the gamma
q p and the S
here and there is
one
object
missing I this one was still in front of
these brackets and that still goes there
gamma qsp I forgot this guy because this
is before the square bracket so there
still the
dxp by
Dyk aha um the only one we still want to
work on a little is this one because
there is the XS with respect to the YJ
and then with respect to the other set
of coordinates XP but look at this there
is a summation here so this entire thing
according to the chain rule is d by d y
k aha so the whole formula becomes well
let me write down here
so in
summary the gamma in the Y system with
coefficients i j
k equals let's start with the last term
it equals the gamma in the X system so I
should
have denoted this x because it has been
calculated from the X system in the X
system with IND indices
qsp and then there are three
transformation matrices in front of
course constructed from the chart
transition map um and they are Yi
because this gives you a y index here uh
xq and then the other y's are here
they're the JK Y and they're the SPs
XS XP and if this last term that I wrote
down was all of it you would see oh in
that case these were the components or
coefficient functions of a one two
tenser but that is not the only term
there is an additional term and now look
at this guy this is DYI dxq DYI by
dxq and then there comes a second
derivative of XS with respect to First y
j and then with respect to y k and now
be very careful whenever you see you
could have said this was already a
second derivative XS by dxp and the dyj
and you think oh you could exchange this
XP and YJ according to schwarz's rule
right that you can exchange coant
derivatives well first of all these are
the symbol so this is not schwarz's rule
in the first place you have to go down
to the Chart but it doesn't reduce to
schwarz's rule because these are your D
coordinates Y and you have another D
coordinates y but it's another
coordinate set and then the Schwarz rule
doesn't apply whereas because of this
here we brought it to the form second
derivative with respect to twice the
same set of coordinates here the Schwarz
rule is inherited by the
symbol okay so if you have y y down here
you can exchange if you have YX down
here you can't very important very
common mistake okay that's this and now
ah and there's a Delta Qs um oh and
there's another no this one we took Del
Qs so the S is a
Q and where has the gamma gone in the
second piece there is not even a gammer
in the second
piece why is this important well first
of all it destroys the tensor
transformation law the gamas Do Not the
tensor component transformation the
gamas Do Not transform as one two tensor
components but even more importantly
because there's no more gamma in this
term even if in some coordinate system
the gamas are zero you go to another one
and because there is no gamma here to
zero that part it will make out of
nothing out of zero it will make non
Vanishing
gamas for what kind of chart
transformation Maps well for those where
the second derivative is non-trivial so
for linear change of chart say you're in
what you call a cesan coordinate system
I would call the normal coordinate
system and you just do a rot
that's a linear transformation you don't
feel it yet because this second
derivative drops out so for anything if
you have in a coordinate system and you
restrict yourself to only looking at
linear Transformations on your position
space so to speak because these are
coordinates then you never feel this
term this is one of the reasons why in
special relativity one thinks it's
clever in position space to only look at
Laurence trans well in the tangent
spaces I fully understand but in
position space why would I not introduce
polar coordinates which make this a
nonzero entity here which means even if
before you were in a system where the
gamas are zero in the new system they
are not because this is this
inhomogeneous term with respect to gamma
the gamma cannot null it it's a very
important point to realize and it shows
you for tensors let's look at this again
if this was a tensor it's a general rule
for tensors if tensor components vanish
in one frame then they vanish in any
frame because the new frame is still
homogeneously dependent on this gamma if
it's zero it's zero huh but the gamas
are simply not of that type they can
vanish totally in one frame in one sorry
in one chart even across the entire
manifold in each of the charts but they
still do not in others that's one way to
look at if you change charts but another
thing is is again changing charts if the
charts overlap if I choose the gamma X
in the U region and I choose fully
independently the gamas like this the
gamma y in the v y region I get a
problem in the intersection unless the
choice of these in the other region
obeys this relation to the other choice
so you cannot freely choose this in
every chart but in the overlap regions
this can be read as a compatibility
condition so whatever way you read it
this is a very important formula it
should also be committed to
memory it's the um
change of
connection
coefficient
functions under
change of chart
from uux or let's rather say from U
intersected vx to u intered v
y so and now because the question was
asked give me five more minutes and I
explain normal
coordinates and how you can get them and
how you cannot get them
normal
coordinates let P be a point uh of a
manifold with connection so assume some
connection is given we think of the
abstract
connection as given so also say the
manifold can be equipped with such a
connection and that's this
um now the question is can you find a
coordinate system that makes the gamas
vanish that's an interesting question
because apparently the formula becomes
simpler well there is a result but the
result is rather
sobering and you can already see it I
started with fixing one single
point and indeed having chosen a point
in that order you can find
coordinates then
U then one then one can
construct a
chart
ux that contains the
point one still hopes one can construct
a chart such that in this chart if it's
small enough it vanishes know you can
construct a chart that contains the
point such
that the
gamma J JK with respect to this chart
map
vanishes but only at that
point at the point
P
not in any
neighborhood
um not
necessarily in any neighborhood of
course if the manifold has a certain
property which we will call flatness
I'll Define in a second uh or flatness
in a region then the gamas can be found
in an extended region but if the
manifold is not flat like for for
example this hyperbolic space it's R2 as
a smooth
manifold and you ask what does this
shape have to do with the coant
derivative well that will be the next
lecture but trust me it has to do with
the shape the coant derivative gives the
space shape okay uh on this
space um you can go to a point and you
can find a coordinate system and you
have to choose the entire coordinate
system in the neighborhood of that point
and you need to choose it such that at
this point the gamas are zero but in you
will not manage to find a coordinate
system such that in the smallest
neighborhood it's everywhere zero okay
uh proof that's interesting enough to to
show it's also a good exercise so
um aha so
assume so um let v
y be a b any
chart uh with P in V so we start with
some chart uh pick any and there in
general the gamas won't
vanish uh
thus in general unless you were just
lucky um the gamas with respect to this
y chart i j k will be nonzero so
generically they will not be all zero
question how do I get from this chart
you picked whatever chart you picked how
do I get this chart
constructively then consider this
transformation
law what you want you want this part to
cancel whatever comes from that
part for this part you need to know the
second derivative and that's the second
derivative KJ with respect to the chart
transition Map X after y
inverse then consider a new
chart
ux to
which one
transits by
virtue of the chart transition Map X
after y inverse that
eats
chart numbers elements in Rd
and I Define this as the
identity so I want the ice component in
the new chart should be the ice
component in the Old Chart well then
nothing will happen then these will be
deltas and this will be zero nothing
will happen so I need to do something
different uh I need to put a plus or a
minus I don't know I will decide in a
second Plus or a minus and I add the
gamma i j K's of the old chart of the Y
chart and I multiply by Alpha K and
alpha alpha J Alpha K you say how can
you multiply these numbers into well on
the chart you can do whatever you wish
this is just Rd to Rd you do what you
want okay and I take this only at the
point P okay and the point P if you want
to write it out is uh X inverse of alpha
1 to Alpha d
so now let's calculate what we need to
know let's calculate the chart the first
and the second derivative of the chart
transition map the first oh already
wrong uh so DX I by
Dy
B what is this this is DB of x i after y
inverse according to the symbol
right um but what is this well this is
just this map with respect to the be
entry is with respect to Alpha B so this
gives you a Delta I plus minus I will
decide in a second you derive here so
you get a factor of two so probably I
need a 1 half here after all I put a 1
half here so it gives you a factor two
it gives you a
gamma ah if it's not ah okay my
statement is wrong uh then one can
construct a chart with that such that
the symmetric part of this guy vanishes
the symmetric part vanishes okay and uh
so here I put only the symmetric part of
this and then the one half will serve me
well so I will get gamma uh I in the Y
system with respect to J and the K
becomes the B and there's an alpha J
left and this is still at the position P
that's the first derivative and now for
good measure I'll do the second
derivative by d y aha I should have
probably used uh here this index J
in order to easily plug in this later on
I J and here then I have an
MJ index Collision which I just resolved
and then I have here a Dy J and a Dy K I
believe yes exactly equals well that's
yet the next derivative of this guy uh
this gives a zero and yet another
derivatives yields a plus or minus gamma
I uh
k j in the Y system evaluated at the
point P but if I now want to find out
what is the gamma in the X system I what
are the components i j
k all I need to do I need to take the
old gamma and and I want to know this at
the point
P want to know this at the point p and I
only want to know about the symmetrized
part
I take the old gamma and I plug in twice
this derivative at the point P so I need
to evaluate this I didn't evaluate it at
P because I had to derive another time
but once I want to evaluate at P all of
these I evaluated at P especially these
two first of all and then you see if I
evaluate at p i if I had been clever I
would have chosen the chart y here
without loss of generality such that the
coordinat of the point P are zero if
that's not the case I can move the chart
so without loss of generality so if I
evaluate at p i evaluate at Alpha equals
Zer that means it would yield Delta i j
so it means the DX I by Dy J is Delta i
j at the point but you calculate on the
last problem sheet I think that the
inverse that this Matrix is the inverse
of this at the point the inverse of
Delta is Delta so what happens to the
gamas in the X system the Delta Delta
Delta the gamma is in the Y system and
that's i j k at P after evaluated the
Deltas then comes the correction term
plus here it is this is again evaluate
all at the point p is a Delta IQ so it's
dxi by KJ that's exactly this guy so
this is plus plus minus which I wasn't
sure of uh gamma um I
KJ in the Y system at the point p and
now I see I need to choose the minus
sign here because if I choose the minus
sign this is in the chart construction
to which chart I go I have the minus
sign the minus minus minus sign and you
get zero but uh this was only the
symmetrized part of it so the
symmetrized part of it I can make to
vanish and later on we will see that the
anti- symmetric part of this gamma is a
tensor that can be set consistently to
zero if you wish um assume you have this
tensor it's called the torsion set to
zero you have the
theorem that in a torsion for torsion
free connection you can always make the
gamma vanish by appropriate choice of a
chart this is the constructive proof to
vanish at a given point and you can
later on also show along the straight
lines not only at a point but along a
straight line but certainly not in a
neighborhood okay yes here you used a
particular construction yes so you
probably can convince me that this
particular construction will not give
Yas in the neighborhood how do I know
that there is not way to construct the
different in a different manner that's
right the final theorem of the next
lecture uh will state that on uh if and
only if both torsion and curvature of a
connection vanish then and only then can
you find an extended coordinate system
where the gamas all vanish so a
Vanishing curvature tensor which we're
going to Define in the next lecture or a
non-vanishing curvature tensor is the
obstruction to extending this beyond the
point so there will be a clear
quantification of when you can and when
you can't and the result in uh uh in
everyday language is if the manifold is
flat which we're going to Define then
then you can find an extended coordinate
system where the gamas uh vanish
throughout if and only if the manifold
is flood and torsion free next lecture
okay exctly continuing on that remark if
I just redefine my to be just that that
Ian would
be no but this is only at one point the
point has been chosen first first pick a
point and then do this construction
where these coefficients are the numbers
at that point if you say away from that
point it needs to look differently that
would amount to making this dependent on
an X that varies with the
alphas but then this is no longer of
this quadratic form then these
derivatives no longer reduce here to the
Deltas and and and to the um uh and to
this form here so if the p is not
fixed then you have a problem so
probably this is uh misleading here
because the p is chosen from the
beginning and for this P you construct
this by using the gamas at the P but you
can't go away because then you upset
this uh logic of this uh this game here
but you're absolutely right I Prov to
you that at a point you can make the
symmetric part vanish the stronger
Converse uh will be part will be the
final theorem of the next
lecture
yes yes so so you say the the the
symmetric part of this
here um no I shouldn't have the so it's
like this in the new system the gamas
are the gamas in the old system minus
the symmetrized gamas in the old system
that means what remains is the gamma I
in the system JK at the point P the
antisymmetrized part remains so you
can start in the Y system with arbitrary
gamma and you can remove the symmetric
contribution now this here will turn out
in the next lecture to be a
tensor with components in the Y system i
j k but because it's a tensor if I
require it vanish in one system it will
vanish in every system so I can look at
special types of connections where this
tensor vanishes those are called
torsionfree
connections if we restrict attention to
torsion free connections we have the
easily memorable theorem you can always
make the gamas vanish at a point and
here you must say in this generality you
can always make the symmetric part of
the gamas vanish but it's the symmetric
part that has the funny transformation
Behavior because you see here the in
inhomogeneous part y y
is symmetric here that means if you
change coordinate system then the anti-
symmetric part of the gamma doesn't get
a contribution well of course not
because if it is a tensor it must
transform like this it must not feel
this okay so from already here you can
read off that the antisymmetric part of
the gamas must be a
tensor okay this will be part of the
next
lecture okay
did you WR oh um I constructed this
chart transition map I calculated the
first and the second derivative here
according to the definition of the
symbol I then want to calculate this guy
at the point P so I go to the formula
here and I evaluate at P then I have to
evaluate
everything at
P now once I have this first derivative
that looks like this but if I evaluate
at p and I cleverly choose the chart I
move it like this it's a centered chart
then this is just a Delta and I can
execute these here all by setting I to q
s to J P to K and so on and for this
second bit here I evaluate at P by doing
nothing because this is constant in the
first place because this P was in here
from the beginning even before I
evaluated on
P because this is the construction for
this chart transition map it's designed
to make the symmetric part of the gamas
vanish at the point p and this is
constructive you can always do
that and uh so these coordinates so
terminology last word on this
terminology uh v y no V ux
ux is
called a normal
coordinate
chart so this is probably what one might
have called kesian coordinates but uh
there is no angle or something implied
these are called at this structural
level you can talk about cesan
coordinates at the metric level we're
still at the lower structure level you
call these normal coordinates ux is
called a normal coordinate chart of this
connection nabla at the point
p and that's that's important at a point
you have normal coordinates at a point
and if we introduce curvature
non-vanishing curvature
obstructs extending this to a region to
a neighborhood around the
point
yes okay so what I say is I calculate
the gamas in the new system from the
gamas in the old system
and that I do according to this rule
there is no symmetrization in here in
the first place so I just apply this
Rule now in this definition of change of
chart I put the symmetrization brackets
already but I didn't have to because I
write Alpha J Alpha K that will
symmetrize automatically see one of the
tutorials because this is clearly
symmetric under exchange of J and K
because of the commutativity of
multiplication in the real numbers so
this implies this here and then
following this through evaluating at the
point P I start on the left of this
formula no symmetrization bracket I
evaluate at P gives you Delta Delta
Delta of this guy this is what's left
without symmetrization bracket minus but
that there's a symmetrization bracket
here comes from this
calculation which where you first derive
with respect to Alpha it is clever to
set it there because if I didn't like I
did here by accident and you do the
derivative uh you would have to put down
two two summons because the product rule
but if it's symmetric I have to exp make
this
explicit sorry make and this goes
through down here and so what is
subtracted it has the symmetrization
bracket and then you have the
unsymmetrized gamas in the Y system
minus the symmetrized gamas in the Y
system are the antisymmetric part in the
Y system it's not true that it's zero no
the symmetric part is zero I corrected
at the end I said my statement was wrong
I uh corrected to you can make the
symmetrized part
vanish ah no very wrong okay sorry so so
this was before because I was thinking
with zero torsion which I shouldn't
because I didn't say anything like this
so this is this this continues to here
and this thing is just called the
torsion so up to the torsion you can
make it vanish
and if you look then at special
connections where you require the
torsion to vanish which is s such um
just a subset of the connections um uh
then you can make the whole gamma vanish
but that's of course
yeah okay thank you very much let's
reconvene at uh a quarter pass half an
hour okay thank you very much